There's this idea in union psychology
called the circumambulation and young
had this idea that you had a potential
future self which would be in potential
everything that you could be and that it
manifests itself moment to moment in
your present life by making you
interested in things and the things that
you're interested in are the things that
would guide you along the path that
would lead you to maximal development.
Now it sounds like a metaphysical idea
or a or a mystical idea even,
but,
but it's not.
It's not.
It's a really profoundly biological
idea.
The idea is something like,
well,
your setup so that you're automatically
interested in those things that was
fully expand you as a well adapted
creature.
Well,
like there's nothing radical about that
idea.
How else,
what else could possibly be the case
unless there's something fundamentally
flawed about you that is what the
situation would be.
It's kind of interesting to think about
how that would be manifest moment to
moment,
but the idea is something like,
well,
your interest is captured by those
things that lead you down the path of
development.
Will that better be the case?
Okay,
so that's fine,
and so there's some utility in pursuing
those things that you're interested in
and that's the call to adventure,
let's say.
So in the call to adventure takes you
all sorts of places.
Now the problem with the call to
adventure is like,
what the hell do you know?
You might be interested in things that
are kind of warped and bent and often
it's the case that when new parts of
people manifest themselves and grip
their interest,
say they do it very badly and shoddily
and so you stumble around like an idiot.
When you try to do something new,
that's where the fool is the precursor
to the savior from the,
from the symbolic perspectives.
Because you have to be a fool before you
can be a master and if you're not
willing to be a fool and you can't be a
master,
so so you're going to.
It's an error error ridden process and
that's also laid out the old testament
stories because the first thing that
happens to all these patriarchal
figures,
when God kicks them out of their
father's house when they're like 84,
is that they.
They run into all sorts of trouble and
some of it's social and some of it's
natural,
some of it's a consequence of their own
moral inadequacy,
so they're fools and.
But,
but the thing that's so interesting is
that despite the fact that they're
fools,
they're still supposed to go on the
adventure and that they're capable of
learning enough as a consequence of
moving forward on the adventure so that
they straightened themselves out across
time.
And so it's something like this and this
circumambulation that young talked about
was this continual,
we'll return to this.
This continual circling in some sense of
who you could be.
You might notice,
for example,
that there are themes in your life.
You know,
when you go back across your
experiences,
you see,
you kind of have your typical experience
that sort of repeats itself and there
might be variation on it,
like a musical theme,
but it's,
it's like you're circling yourself and
getting closer to yourself as you move
across time.
That's the circumambulation.
Now you remember that for a sec because
we'll go back to it.
Okay,
so imagine that something glimmers
before you.
It's an an interest that's dawning and
you decide,
well,
first of all,
you're paralyzed.
You think,
well,
how do I know if I should pursue that?
It's probably a stupid idea,
and the proper response to that is,
you're right.
It probably is a stupid idea because
almost all the all ideas are stupid and
so the probability that as you move
forward on your adventure that you're
going to get it right.
The first time is zero.
It's just not going to happen,
and so then you might think,
well,
maybe I'll just wait around until I get
the right idea and which people do.
Right?
So they're like 40 year old,
13 year olds,
which is not a good idea.
So they wait around until it's waiting
for Godot until they finally got it
right.
But the problem is you're too stupid to
know when you've got it right.
So waiting around isn't going to help
because even if the perfect opportunity
manifested itself to you in your
incomplete form,
the probability that you would recognize
it as the perfect opportunity is zero.
You might even think it's the worst
possible idea that you've ever heard of
anywhere,
highly likely,
highly likely.
So,
so you ha,
there's a niche,
a niche called that,
uh,
will,
will to stupidity,
which I really liked.
So because he thought of stupidity as
being,
you know,
it's,
you have to take it into account
fundamentally and work with it.
And so,
and so you can take these tentative
steps on your pathway to destiny and you
can assume that you're going to do it
badly.
And that's really useful because you
don't have to beat yourself up.
It's pretty easy to do it badly.
But the thing is,
it's way better to do it badly the not
to do it at all.
And that's the continual message that
echoes through these historical stories
in genesis.
It's like these are flawed people.
They should have got the hell out of
their house way before they did.
Um,
and they go out and they stumble around
in tyranny and feminine self betrayal
and,
and violence.
And,
but it's a hell of a lot better than
just rotting away at home.
And that's the,
that's great.
So that's good and so why is that?
Well,
okay,
so you,
you start your path and you think that
you're heading towards your star and so
you go in that direction and then
because you're here,
the world looks a particular way,
but then when you move here,
the world looks different and you're
different as a consequence of having
made that voyage.
And so what that means is that now that
thing that glimmers in front of you is
going to have shifted its location
because you weren't very good at
specifying it to begin with and now that
you're a little sharper and more focused
than you were,
it's going to reveal itself with more
accuracy to you.
And so then you have to take a,
you know,
it's almost like 180 degree reversal,
but it isn't because you know,
you've,
I mean you've gone this far and that's a
long ways to get that far,
but that's a lot farther than you would
be if you just stayed where you were
waiting.
And so it doesn't matter that you
overshoot continually because as you
overshoot,
even if you don't learn what you
should've done,
you're going to continually learn what
you shouldn't keep doing.
And if you learn enough about what you
shouldn't keep doing,
then that's tantamount at some point to
learning at the same time what you
should be doing.
So it's okay.
So it's like this.
Now what's cool about it though,
I think is that as you progress,
the degree of overshooting starts to
decline,
right?
And that we know that there's nothing
hypothetical about that.
As you learn a new skill,
like even to play it,
play a song on the piano,
for example,
you overshoot madly,
you're making all sorts of mistakes to
begin with.
And then the mistakes they disappear.
There's a great ted talk,
I think it was about this guy a up a
really advanced computational recording
system in his home and recorded every
single utterance his young child made
while learning to speak.
And then he put together the child's
attempts to say certain phonemes and put
them in list and you can hear the child
deviating madly to begin with.
And then after hundreds and hundreds of
repetitions,
just zeroing right in on the exact
phoneme so you know you might not know
this,
but when kids babble,
because they start babbling when they're
quite young,
they babble every human phoneme
including all sorts of phonemes that
adults can't say,
and then they they die into their
language so that after they learned,
say English,
then there's all sorts of phonemes they
can no longer here or pronounced,
but to begin with,
it's all there.
Just really quite interesting.
But so they Z,
as they learn a particular language,
they zero in on the proper way to
pronounce that and their errors
minimize.
And every time you learn something,
that's how it is.
And that's really useful to know too
because it means that it's okay to
wander around stupidly before you fix
your destination.
Now you see that echoed in exodus,
right?
Because what happens is that the
Egyptians or the Hebrews escape
materiality,
which is kind of whatever you do
personally and psychologically,
when you escape from your previous set
of stupidly held and ignorant and
stubborn axioms,
it's like away from that tyranny.
It's like,
great.
I freed myself from that.
Well then what?
Well you think,
well,
now I'm on the way.
It's no,
you're not.
Now you're in the desert where you
wander around stupidly,
you know and worship the wrong things
until you finally organize yourself
morally again and head in the proper
direction,
so that's worth knowing too because you
think,
well,
I got rid of a lot of things,
baggage,
excess baggage that I didn't need in my
life,
and now everything's okay.
It's like,
no,
it's not.
You've got rid of a whole set of
scaffolds that were keeping you in place
even though they were pathological.
Now you have nothing and nothing
actually turns out to be better than
something pathological,
but you're still stuck with the problem
of nothing,
and that's well,
that's exactly why exodus is structured
the way that it is.
It's that you escaped from maturity.
It's hooray.
We're no longer slaves.
Yeah,
well now you're nihilistic and lost.
It's not necessarily an improvement,
but it is,
but it is the pre.
See,
it's also useful to know that because
you can also be diluted into the idea
that imagine that you're trying to
become enlightened,
which might mean to turn all those parts
of you on that could be turned on.
You think,
well,
that's just a linear pathway uphill.
You know,
it's just from one success to another.
It's no,
it's not.
It's like here you are and you're not
doing too badly in the first step is a
complete bloody catastrophe.
It's worse and then maybe you can pull
yourself together and you hit a new
plateau and then that crumbles and
shakes and bang.
It's worse again and so because part of
the reason that people don't become
enlightened is because it's punctuated
by intermittent deserts essentially by
intermittent catastrophes,
and if you don't know that well,
then you're basically screwed because
you go ahead on your movement forward
and you collapse and you think,
well,
that didn't work.
I collapsed.
It's like,
no,
that's par for the course.
It's not indication that you failed.
It's just indication that it's really
hard and that when you learn something,
you also unlearn something and the thing
you unlearned is probably useful and
unlearning it actually is painful.
You know,
let's say if you have to get out of a
bad relationship,
it's like not every,
not any real.
There isn't any relationship that's a
hundred percent bad,
and so when you jump out of it,
well maybe you're in better shape,
but you're still lonesome and
disoriented and you don't know what your
past was and you don't know what your
present isn't.
He don't want know what your future is.
It's that's not.
That's why people stay with the devil
they know instead of you know,
looking for the devil they don't know
so,
so anyways,
the fact that you're full of faults
doesn't mean you have to stop and thank
God for that.
That's a really useful thing and the
fact that you're full of faults doesn't
mean that you can't learn and so you can
pause it in an ideal and you're going to
be wrong about it,
but it doesn't matter because what
you're right about his positing,
the ideal moving towards it,
if the actual ideal is conceptualized
perfectly well first surprise,
surprise,
because like what are you going to do?
That's perfect.
So it doesn't matter that it's
imperfect,
it just matters that you do it and that
you move forward.
So that's really,
that's really positive news as far as
I'm concerned because you could actually
do that,
right?
You can do it badly.
Anyone can do that.
So that's,
that's useful.
Okay.
So like if you were an efficient person,
you would have just done that but you're
not.
But who cares,
you know,
and you still end up in the,
in the same place and maybe the trip is
even more interesting.
Who knows?
Probably too interesting.